-- shortest paths.
This is the finale.
Hopefully it was worth waiting
for.
Remind you there's a quiz
coming up soon,
you should be studying for it.
There's no problem set due at
the same time as the quiz
because you should be studying
now.
It's a take-home exam.
It's required that you come to
class on Monday.
Of course, you'll all come,
but everyone watching at home
should also come next Monday to
get the quiz.
It's the required lecture.
So, we need a bit of a recap in
the trilogy so far.
So, the last two lectures,
the last two episodes,
or about single source shortest
paths.
So, we wanted to find the
shortest path from a source
vertex to every other vertex.
And, we saw a few algorithms
for this.
Here's some recap.
We saw in the unweighted case,
that was sort of the easiest
where all the edge weights were
one.
Then we could use breadth first
search.
And this costs what we call
linear time in the graph world,
the number of vertices plus the
number of edges.
The next simplest case,
perhaps, is nonnegative edge
weights.
And in that case,
what algorithm do we use?
Dijkstra, all right,
everyone's awake.
Several answers at once,
great.
So this takes almost linear
time if you use a good heap
structure, so,
V log V plus E.
And, in the general case,
general weights,
we would use Bellman-Ford which
you saw.
And that costs VE,
good, OK, which is quite a bit
worse.
This is ignoring log factors.
Dijkstra is basically linear
time, Bellman-Ford you're
quadratic if you have a
connected graph.
So, in the sparse case,
when E is order V,
this is about linear.
This is about quadratic.
In the dense case,
when E is about V^2,
this is quadratic,
and this is cubic.
So, Dijkstra and Bellman-Ford
are separated by about an order
of V factor, which is pretty
bad.
OK, but that's the best we know
how to do for single source
shortest paths,
negative edge weights,
Bellman-Ford is the best.
We also saw in recitation the
case of a DAG.
And there, what do you do?
Topological sort,
yeah.
So, you can do a topological
sort to get an ordering on the
vertices.
That you run Bellman-Ford,
one round.
This is one way to think of
what's going on.
You run Bellman-Ford in the
order given by the topological
sort, which is once,
and you get a linear time
algorithm.
So, DAG is another case where
we know how to do well even with
weights.
Unweighted, we can also do
linear time.
But most of the time,
though, will be,
so you should keep these in
mind in the quiz.
When you get a shortest path
problem, or what you end up
determining is the shortest path
problem, think about what's the
best algorithm you can use in
that case?
OK, so that's single source
shortest paths.
And so, in our evolution of the
Death Star, initially it was
just nonnegative edge weights.
Then we got negative edge
weights.
Today, the Death Star
challenges us with all pair
shortest paths,
where we want to know the
shortest path weight between
every pair of vertices.
OK, so let's get some quick
results.
What could we do with this
case?
So, for example,
suppose I have an unweighted
graph.
Any suggestions of how I should
compute all pair shortest paths?
Between every pair of vertices,
I want to know the shortest
path weight.
BFS, a couple more words?
Yeah?
Right, BFS V times.
OK, I'll say V times BFS,
OK?
So, the running time would be
V^2 plus V times E,
yeah, which is assuming your
graph is connected,
V times E.
OK, good.
That's probably about the best
algorithm we know for unweighted
graphs.
So, a lot of these are going to
sort of be the obvious answer.
You take your single source
algorithm, you run it V times.
That's the best you can do,
OK, or the best we know how to
do.
This is not so bad.
This is like one iteration of
Bellman-Ford,
for comparison.
We definitely need at least,
like, V^2 time,
because the size of the output
is V^2, shortest path weight we
have to compute.
So, this is not perfect,
but pretty good.
And we are not going to improve
on that.
So, nonnegative edge weights:
the natural thing to do is to
run Dijkstra V times,
OK, no big surprise.
And the running time of that
is, well, V times E again,
plus V^2, log V,
which is also not too bad.
I mean, it's basically the same
as running BFS.
And then, there's the log
factor.
If you ignore the log factor,
this is the dominant term.
And, I mean,
this had an [added?] V^2 as
well.
So, these are both pretty good.
I mean, this is kind of neat.
Essentially,
the time it takes to run one
Bellman-Ford plus a log factor,
you can compute all pair
shortest paths if you have
nonnegative edge weights.
So, I mean, comparing all pairs
to signal source,
this seems a lot better,
except we can only handle
nonnegative edge weights.
OK, so now let's think about
the general case.
Well, this is the focus of
today, and here's where we can
actually make an improvement.
So the obvious thing is V times
Bellman-Ford,
which would cost V^2 times E.
And that's pretty pitiful,
and we're going to try to
improve that to something closer
to that nonnegative edge weight
bound.
So it turns out,
here, we can actually make an
improvement whereas in these
special cases,
we really can't do much better.
OK, I don't have a good
intuition why,
but it's the case.
So, we'll cover something like
three algorithms today for this
problem.
The last one will be the best,
but along the way we'll see
some nice connections between
shortest paths and dynamic
programming, which we haven't
really seen yet.
We've seen shortest path,
and applying greedy algorithms
to it, but today will actually
do dynamic programming.
The intuition is that with all
pair shortest paths,
there's more potential
subproblem reuse.
We've got to compute the
shortest path from x to y for
all x and y.
Maybe we can reuse those
shortest paths in computing
other shortest paths.
OK, there's a bit more
reusability, let's say.
OK, let me quickly define all
pair shortest paths formally,
because we're going to change
our notation slightly.
It's because we care about all
pairs.
So, as usual,
the input is directed graph,
so, vertices and edges.
We're going to say that the
vertices are labeled one to n
for convenience because with all
pairs, we're going to think of
things more as an n by n matrix
instead of edges in some sense
because it doesn't help to think
any more in terms of adjacency
lists.
And, you have edge weights as
usual.
This is what makes it
interesting.
Some of them are going to be
negative.
So, w maps to every real
number, and the target output is
a shortest path matrix.
So, this is now an n by n
matrix.
So, n is just the number of
vertices of shortest path
weights.
So, delta of i,
j is the shortest path weight
from i to j for all pairs of
vertices.
So this, you could represent as
an n by n matrix in particular.
OK, so now let's start doing
algorithms.
So, we have this very simple
algorithm, V times Bellman-Ford,
V^2 times E,
and just for comparison's sake,
I'm going to say,
let me rewrite that,
V times Bellman-Ford gives us
this running time of V^2 E,
and I'm going to think about
the case where,
let's just say the graph is
dense, meeting that the number
of edges is quadratic,
and the number of vertices.
So in that case,
this will take V^4 time,
which is pretty slow.
We'd like to do better.
So, first goal would just be to
beat V^4, V hypercubed,
I guess.
OK, and we are going to use
dynamic programming to do that.
Or at least that's what the
motivation will come from.
It will take us a while before
we can even beat V^4,
which is maybe a bit pathetic,
but it takes some clever
insights, let's say.
OK, so I'm going to introduce a
bit more notation for this
graph.
So, I'm going to think about
the weighted adjacency matrix.
So, I don't think we've really
seen this in lecture before,
although I think it's in the
appendix.
What that means,
so normally adjacency matrix is
like one if there's an edge,
and zero if there isn't.
And this is in a digraph,
so you have to be a little bit
careful.
Here, these values,
the entries in the matrix,
are going to be the weights of
the edges.
OK, this is this if ij is an
edge.
So, if ij is an edge in the
graph, and it's going to be
infinity if there is no edge.
OK, in terms of shortest paths,
this is a more useful way to
represent the graph.
All right, and so this includes
everything that we need from
here.
And now we just have to think
about it as a matrix.
Matrices will be a useful tool
in a little while.
OK, so now I'm going to define
some sub problems.
And, there's different ways
that you could define what's
going on in the shortest paths
problem.
OK, the natural thing is I want
to go from vertex i to vertex j.
What's the shortest path?
OK, we need to refine the sub
problems a little but more than
that.
Not surprising.
And if you think about my
analogy to Bellman-Ford,
what Bellman-Ford does is it
tries to build longer and longer
shortest paths.
But here, length is in terms of
the number of edges.
So, first, it builds shortest
paths of length one.
We've proven the first round it
does that.
The second round,
it provides all shortest paths
of length two,
of count two,
and so on.
We'd like to do that sort of
analogously, and try to reuse
things a little bit more.
So, I'm going to say d_ij^(m)
is the weight of the shortest
path from i to j with some
restriction involving m.
So: shortest path from i to j
using at most m edges.
OK, for example,
if m is zero,
then we don't have to really
think very hard to find all
shortest paths of length zero.
OK, they use zero edges,
I should say.
So, Bellman-Ford sort of tells
us how to go from m to m plus
one.
So, let's just figure that out.
So one thing we know from the
Bellman-Ford analysis is if we
look at d_ij^(m-1),
we know that in some sense the
longest shortest path of
relevance, unless you have
negative weight cycle,
the longest shortest path of
relevance is when m equals n
minus one because that's the
longest simple path you can
have.
So, this should be a shortest
path weight from i to j,
and it would be no matter what
larger value you put in the
superscript.
This should be delta of i comma
j if there's no negative weight
cycles.
OK, so this feels good for
dynamic programming.
This will give us the answer if
we can compute this for all m.
Then we'll have the shortest
path weights in particular.
We need a way to detect
negative weight cycles,
but let's not worry about that
too much for now.
There are negative weights,
but let's just assume for now
there's no negative weight
cycles.
OK, and we get a recursion
recurrence.
And the base case is when m
equals zero.
This is pretty easy.
They have the same vertices,
the weight of zero,
and otherwise it's infinity.
OK, and then the actual
recursion is for m.
OK, if I got this right,
this is a pretty easy,
intuitive recursion for
d_ij^(m) is a min of smaller
things in terms of n minus one.
I'll just show the picture,
and then the proof of that
claim should be obvious.
So, this is proof by picture.
So, we have on the one hand,
I over here,
and j over here.
We want to know the shortest
path from i to j.
And, we want to use,
at most, m edges.
So, the idea is,
well, you could use m minus one
edges to get somewhere.
So this is, at most,
m minus one edges,
some other place,
and we'll call it k.
So this is a candidate for k.
And then you could take the
edge directly from k to j.
So, this costs A_k^j,
and this costs DIK m minus one.
OK, and that's a candidate path
of length that uses,
at most, m edges from I to j.
And this is essentially just
considering all of them.
OK, so there's sort of many
paths we are considering.
All of these are candidate
values of k.
We are taking them in over all
k as intermediate nodes,
whatever.
So there they are.
We take the best such path.
That should encompass all
shortest paths.
And this is essentially sort of
what Bellman-Ford is doing,
although not exactly.
We also sort of want to think
about, well, what if I just go
directly with,
say, m minus one edges?
What if there is no edge here
that I want to use,
in some sense?
Well, we always think about
there being, and the way the A's
are defined, there's always this
zero weight edge to yourself.
So, you could just take a path
that's shorter,
go from d i to j,
and j is a particular value of
k that we might consider,
and then take a zero weight
edge at the end from A and jj.
OK, so this really encompasses
everything.
So that's a pretty trivial
claim.
OK, now once we have such a
recursion, we get a dynamic
program.
I mean, there,
this is it in some sense.
It's written recursively.
You can write a bottom up.
And I would like to write it
bottom up it little bit because
while it doesn't look like it,
this is a relaxation.
This is yet another relaxation
algorithm.
So, I'll give you,
so, this is sort of the
algorithm.
This is not a very interesting
So, you don't have to write it
all down if you don't feel like
it.
It's probably not even in the
book.
This is just an intermediate
step.
So, we loop over all m.
That's sort of the outermost
thing to do.
I want to build longer and
longer paths,
and this vaguely corresponds to
Bellman-Ford,
although it's actually worse
than Bellman-Ford.
But hey, what the heck?
It's a stepping stone.
OK, then for all i and j,
and then we want to compute
this min.
So, we'll just loop over all k,
and relax.
And, here's where we're
actually computing the min.
And, it's a relaxation,
is the point.
This is our good friend,
the relaxation step,
relaxing edge.
Well, it's not,
yeah.
I guess we're relaxing edge kj,
or something,
except we don't have the same
clear notion.
I mean, it's a particular thing
that we're relaxing.
It's not just a single edge
because we don't have a single
source anymore.
It's now relative to source I,
we are relaxing the edge kj,
something like that.
But this is clearly a
relaxation.
We are just making the triangle
inequality true if it wasn't
before.
The tribal inequality has got
to hold between all pairs.
And that's just implementing
this min, right?
You're taking d ij.
You take the min of what it was
before in some sense.
That was one of the
possibilities we considered when
we looked at the zero weight
edge.
We say, well,
or you could go from i to some
k in some way that we knew how
to before, and then add on the
edge, and check whether that's
better if it's better,
set our current estimate to
that.
And, you do this for all k.
In particular,
you might actually compute
something smaller than this min
because I didn't put
superscripts up here.
But that's just making paths
even better.
OK, so you have to argue that
relaxation is always a good
thing to do.
So, by not putting
superscripts,
maybe I do some more
relaxation, but more relaxation
never hurts us.
You can still argue correctness
using this claim.
So, it's not quite the direct
implementation,
but there you go,
dynamic programming algorithm.
The main reason I'll write it
down: so you see that it's a
relaxation, and you see the
running time is n^4,
OK, which is certainly no
better than Bellman-Ford.
Bellman-Ford was n^4 even in
the dense case,
and it's a little better in the
sparse case.
So: not doing so great.
But it's a start.
OK, it gets our dynamic
programming minds thinking.
And, we'll get a better dynamic
program in a moment.
But first, there's actually
something useful we can do with
this formulation,
and I guess I'll ask,
but I'll be really impressed if
anyone can see.
Does this formula look like
anything else that you've seen
in any context,
mathematical or algorithmic?
Have you seen that recurrence
anywhere else?
OK, not exactly as stated,
but similar.
I'm sure if you thought about
it for awhile,
you could come up with it.
Any answers?
I didn't think you would be
very intuitive,
but the answer is matrix
multiplication.
And it may now be obvious to
you, or it may not.
You have to think with the
right quirky mind.
Then it's obvious that it's
matrix multiplication.
Remember, matrix
multiplication,
we have A, B,
and C.
They're all n by n matrices.
And, we want to compute C
equals A times B.
And what that meant was,
well, c_ij was a sum over all k
of a_ik times b_kj.
All right, that was our
definition of matrix
multiplication.
And that formula looks kind of
like this one.
I mean, notice the subscripts:
ik and kj.
Now, the operators are a little
different.
Here, we're multiplying the
inside things and adding them
all together.
There, we're adding the inside
things and taking them in.
But other than that,
it's the same.
OK, weird, but here we go.
So, the connection to shortest
paths is you replace these
operators.
So, let's take matrix
multiplication and replace,
what should I do first,
plus this thing with min.
So, why not just change the
operators, replace dot with
plus?
This is just a different
algebra to work in,
where plus actually means min,
and dot actually means plus.
So, you have to check that
things sort of work out in that
context, but if we do that,
then we get that c_ij is the
min overall k of a_ik plus,
a bit messy here,
b_kj.
And that looks like what we
actually want to compute,
here, for one value of m,
you have to sort of do this m
times.
But this conceptually is
d_ij^(m), and this is
d_ik^(m-1).
So, this is looking like a
matrix product,
which is kind of cool.
So, if we sort of plug in this
claim, then, and think about
things as matrices,
the recurrence gives us,
and I'll just write this now at
matrix form, that d^(m) is d^(m)
minus one, funny product,
A.
All right, so these are the
weights.
These were the weighted
adjacency matrix.
This was the previous d value.
This is the new d value.
So, I'll just rewrite that in
matrix form with capital
letters.
OK, I have the circle up things
that are using this funny
algebra, so, in particular,
circled product.
OK, so that's kind of nifty.
We know something about
computing matrix
multiplications.
We can do it in n^3 time.
If we were a bit fancier,
maybe we could do it in
sub-cubic time.
So, we could try to sort of use
this connection.
And, well, think about what we
are computing here.
We are saying,
well, d to the m is the
previous one times A.
So, what is d^(m)?
Is that some other algebraic
notion that we know?
Yeah, it's the exponent.
We're taking A,
and we want to raise it to the
power, m, with this funny notion
of product.
So, in other words,
d to the m is really just A to
the m in a funny way.
So, I'll circle it,
OK?
So, that sounds good.
We also know how to compute
powers of things relatively
quickly, if you remember how.
OK, for this notion,
this power notion,
to make sense,
I should say what A to the zero
means.
And so, I need some kind of
identity matrix.
And for here,
the identity matrix is this
one, if I get it right.
So, it has zeros along the
diagonal, and infinities
everywhere else.
OK, that sort of just to match
this definition.
d_ij zero should be zeros on
the diagonals and infinity
everywhere else.
But you can check this is
actually an identity.
If you multiply it with this
funny multiplication against any
other matrix,
you get the matrix back.
Nothing changes.
This really is a valid identity
matrix.
And, I should mention that for
A to the m to make sense,
you really knew that your
product operation is
associative.
So, actually A to the m circled
makes sense because circled
multiplication is associative,
and you can check that;
not hard because,
I mean, min is associative,
and addition is associative,
and all sorts of good stuff.
And, you have some kind of
distributivity property.
And, this is,
in turn, because the real
numbers with,
and get the right order here,
with min as your addition
operation, and plus as your
multiplication operation is a
closed semi-ring.
So, if ever you want to know
when powers make sense,
this is a good rule.
If you have a closed semi-ring,
then matrix products on that
semi-ring will give you an
associative operator,
and then, good,
you can take products.
OK, that's just some formalism.
So now, we have some intuition.
The question is,
what's the right.
Algorithm?
There are many possible
answers, some of which are
right, some of which are not.
So, we have this connection to
matrix products,
and we have a connection to
matrix powers.
And, we have algorithms for
both.
The question is,
what should we do?
So, all we need to do now is to
compute A to the funny power,
n minus one.
n minus one is when we get
shortest paths,
assuming we have no negative
weight cycles.
In fact, we could compute a
larger power than n minus one.
Once you get beyond n minus
one, multipling by A doesn't
change you anymore.
So, how should we do it?
OK, you're not giving any smart
answers.
I'll give the stupid answer.
You could say,
well, I take A.
I multiply it by A.
Then I multiply it by A,
and I multiply it by A,
and I use normal,
boring matrix to
multiplication.
So, I do, like,
n minus two,
standard matrix multiplies.
So, standard multiply costs,
like, n^3.
And I'm doing n of them.
So, this gives me an n^4
algorithm, and compute all the
shortest pathways in n^4.
Woohoo!
OK, no improvement.
So, how can I do better?
Right, natural thing to try
which sadly does not work,
is to use the sub cubic matrix
multiply algorithm.
We will, in some sense,
get there in a moment with a
somewhat simpler problem.
But, it's actually not known
how to compute shortest paths
using fast matrix multiplication
like Strassen's system
algorithm.
But, good suggestion.
OK, you have to think about why
it doesn't work,
and I'll tell you.
It's not obvious,
so it's a perfectly reasonable
suggestion.
But in this context it doesn't
quite work.
It will come up in a few
moments.
The problem is,
Strassen requires the notion of
subtraction.
And here, addition is min.
And, there's no inverse to min.
Once you take the arguments,
you can't sort of undo a min.
OK, so there's no notion of
subtraction, so it's not known
how to pull that off,
sadly.
So, what other tricks do we
have up our sleeve?
Yeah?
Divide and conquer,
log n powering,
yeah, repeated squaring.
That works.
Good, we had a fancy way.
If you had a number n,
you sort of looked at the
binary number representation of
n, and you either squared the
number or squared it and added
another factor of A.
Here, we don't even have to be
smart about it.
OK, we can just compute,
we really only have to think
about powers of two.
What we want to know,
and I'm going to need a bigger
font here because there's
multiple levels of subscripts,
A to the circled power,
two to the ceiling of log n.
Actually, n minus one would be
enough.
But there you go.
You can write n if you didn't
leave yourself enough space like
me, n the ceiling,
n the circle.
This just means the next power
of two after n minus one,
two to the ceiling log.
So, we don't have to go
directly to n minus one.
We can go further because
anything farther than n minus
one is still just the shortest
pathways.
If you look at the definition,
and you know that your paths
are simple, which is true if you
have no negative weight cycles,
then fine, just go farther.
Why not?
And so, to compute this,
we just do ceiling of log n
minus one products,
just take A squared,
and then take the result and
square it; take the result and
square it.
So, this is order log n
squares.
And, we don't know how to use
Strassen, but we can use the
boring, standard multiply of
n^3, and that gives us n^3 log n
running time,
OK, which finally is something
that beats Bellman-Ford in the
dense case.
OK, in the dense case,
Bellman-Ford was n^4.
Here we get n^3 log n,
finally something better.
In the sparse case,
it's about the same,
maybe a little worse.
E is order V.
Then we're going to get,
like, V3 for Bellman-Ford.
Here, we get n^3 log n.
OK, after log factors,
this is an improvement some of
the time.
OK, it's about the same the
other times.
Another nifty thing that you
get for free out of this,
is you can detect negative
weight cycles.
So, here's a bit of a puzzle.
How would I detect,
after I compute this product,
A to the power to ceiling log n
minus one, how would I know if I
found a negative weight cycle?
What would that mean it this
matrix of all their shortest
paths of, at most,
a certain length?
If I found a cycle,
what would have to be in that
matrix?
Yeah?
Right, so I could,
for example,
take this thing,
multiply it by A,
see if the matrix changed at
all.
Right, that works fine.
That's what we do in
Bellman-Ford.
It's an even simpler thing.
It's already there.
You don't have to multiply.
But that's the same running
time.
That's a good answer.
The diagonal would have a
negative value,
yeah.
So, this is just a cute thing.
Both approaches would work,
can detect a negative weight
cycle just by looking at the
diagonal of the matrix.
You just look for a negative
value in the diagonal.
OK.
So, that's algorithm one,
let's say.
I mean, we've seen several that
are all bad, but I'll call this
number one.
OK, we'll see two more.
This is the only one that will,
well, I shouldn't say that.
Fine, there we go.
So, this is one dynamic program
that wasn't so helpful,
except it showed us a
connection to matrix
multiplication,
which is interesting.
We'll see why it's useful a
little bit more.
But, it bled to this nasty four
nested loops.
And, using this trick,
we got down to n^3 log n.
Let's try, just for n^3.
OK, just get rid of that log.
It's annoying.
It makes you a little bit worse
than Bellman-Ford,
and the sparse case.
So, let's just erase one of
these nested loops.
OK, I want to do that.
OK, obviously that algorithm
doesn't work because it's for
first decay, and it's not
defined, but,
you know, I've got enough
variables.
Why don't I just define k to
the m?
OK, it turns out that works.
I'll do it from scratch,
but why not?
I don't know if that's how
Floyd and Warshall came up with
their algorithm,
but here you go.
Here's Floyd-Warshall.
The idea is to define the
subproblems a little bit more
cleverly so that to compute one
of these values,
you don't have to take the min
of n things.
I just want to take the min of
two things.
If I could do that,
and I still only have n^3
subproblems, then I would have
n^3 time.
So, all right,
the running time of dynamic
program is number of subproblems
times the time to compute the
recurrence for one subproblem.
So, here's linear times n^3,
and we want n^3 times constant.
That would be good.
So that's Floyd-Warshall.
So, here's the way we're going
to redefine c_ij.
Or I guess, there it was called
d_ij.
Good, so we're going to define
something new.
So, c_ij superscript k is now
going to be the weight of the
shortest path from I to j as
before.
Notice I used the superscript k
instead of m because I want k
and m to be the same thing.
Deep.
OK, now, here's the new
constraint.
I want all intermediate
vertices along the path,
meeting all vertices except for
I and j at the beginning and the
end to have a small label.
So, they should be in the set
from one up to k.
And this is where we are really
using that our vertices are
labeled one up to m.
So, I'm going to say,
well, first think about the
shortest paths that don't use
any other vertices.
That's when k is zero.
Then think about all the
shortest paths that maybe they
use vertex one.
And then think about the
shortest paths that maybe use
vertex one or vertex two.
Why not?
You could define it in this
way.
It turns out,
then when you increase k,
you only have to think about
one new vertex.
Here, we had to take min over
all k.
Now we know which k to look at.
OK, maybe that made sense.
Maybe it's not quite obvious
yet.
But I'm going to redo this
claim, redo a recurrence.
So, maybe first I should say
some obvious things.
So, if I want delta of ij of
the shortest pathway,
well, just take all the
vertices.
So, take c_ij superscript n.
That's everything.
And this even works,
this is true even if you have a
negative weight cycle.
Although, again,
we're going to sort of ignore
negative weight cycles as long
as we can detect them.
And, another simple case is if
you have, well,
c_ij to zero.
Let me put that in the claim to
be a little bit more consistent
here.
So, here's the new claim.
If we want to compute c_ij
superscript zero,
what is it?
Superscript zero means I really
shouldn't use any intermediate
vertices.
So, this has a very simple
answer, a three letter answer.
So, it's not zero.
It's four letters.
What's that?
Nil.
No, not working yet.
It has some subscripts,
too.
So, the definition would be,
what's the shortest path weight
from I to j when you're not
allowed to use any intermediate
vertices?
Sorry?
So, yeah, it has a very simple
name.
That's the tricky part.
All right, so if i equals j,
[LAUGHTER] you're clever,
right, open bracket i equals j
means one, well,
OK.
It sort of works,
but it's not quite right.
In fact, I want infinity if i
does not equal j.
And I want to zero if i equals
j, a_ij, good.
I think it's a_ij.
It should be,
right?
Maybe I'm wrong.
Right, a_ij.
So it's essentially not what I
said.
That's the point.
If i does not equal j,
you still have to think about a
single edge connecting i to j,
right?
OK, so that's a bit of a
subtlety.
This is only intermediate
vertices, so you could still go
from i to j via a single edge.
That will cost a_ij.
If there is an edge:
infinity.
If there isn't one:
that is a_ij.
So, OK, that gets us started.
And then, we want a recurrence.
And, the recurrence is,
well, maybe you get away with
all the vertices that you had
before.
So, if you want to know paths
that you had before,
so if you want to know paths
that use one up to k,
maybe I just use one up to k
minus one.
You could try that.
Or, you could try using k.
So, either you use k or you
don't.
If you don't,
it's got to be this.
If you do, then you've got to
go to k.
So why not go to k at the end?
So, you go from I to k using
the previous vertices.
Obviously, you don't want to
repeat k in there.
And then, you go from k to j
somehow using vertices that are
not k.
This should be pretty
intuitive.
Again, I can draw a picture.
So, either you never go to k,
and that's this wiggly line.
You go from i to j using things
only one up to k minus one.
In other words,
here we have to use one up to
k.
So, this just means don't use
So, that's this thing.
Or, you use k somewhere in the
middle there.
OK, it's got to be one of the
two.
And in this case,
you go from i to k using only
smaller vertices,
because you don't want to
repeat k.
And here, you go from k to j
using only smaller labeled
vertices.
So, every path is one of the
two.
So, we take the shortest of
these two subproblems.
That's the answer.
So, now we have a min of two
things.
It takes constant time to
compute.
So, we get a cubic algorithm.
So, let me write it down.
So, this is the Floyd-Warshall
algorithm.
I'll write the name again.
You give it a matrix A.
That's all it really needs to
know.
It codes everything.
You copy C to A.
That's the warm up.
Right at time zero,
C equals A.
And then you just have these
three loops for every value of
k, for every value of i,
and for every value of j.
You compute that min.
And if you think about it a
little bit, that min is a
relaxation.
Surprise, surprise.
So, that is the Floyd-Warshall
algorithm.
And, the running time is
clearly n^3, three nested loops,
constant time inside.
So, we're finally getting
something that is never worse
than Bellman-Ford.
In the sparse case,
it's the same.
And anything denser,
the number of edges is super
linear.
This is strictly better than
Bellman-Ford.
And, it's better than
everything we've seen so far for
all pair, shortest paths.
And, this handles negative
weights; very simple algorithm,
even simpler than the one
before.
It's just relaxation within
three loops.
What more could you ask for?
And we need to check that this
is indeed what min we're
computing here,
except that the superscripts
are omitted.
That's, again,
a bit of hand waving a bit.
It's OK to omit subscripts
because that can only mean that
you're doing more relaxation
techniques should be.
Doing more relaxations can
never hurt you.
In particular,
we do all the ones that we have
to.
Therefore, we find the shortest
path weights.
And, again, here,
we're assuming that there is no
negative weight cycles.
It shouldn't be hard to find
them, but you have to think
about that a little bit.
OK, you could run another round
of Bellman-Ford,
see if it relaxes in a new
edges again.
For example,
I think there's no nifty trick
for that version.
And, we're going to cover,
that's our second algorithm for
all pairs shortest paths.
Before we go up to the third
algorithm, which is going to be
the cleverest of them all,
the one Ring to rule them all,
to switch trilogies,
we're going to take a little
bit of a diversion,
side story, whatever,
and talk about transitive
closure briefly.
This is just a good thing to
know about.
And, it relates to the
algorithms we've seen so far.
So, here's a transitive closure
problem.
I give you a directed graph,
and for all pair vertices,
i and j, I want to compute this
number.
It's one if there's a path from
i to j.
From i to j,
OK, and then zero otherwise.
OK, this is sort of like a
boring adjacency matrix with no
weights, except it's about paths
instead of being about edges.
OK, so how can I compute this?
That's very simple.
How should I compute this?
This gives me a graph in some
sense.
This is adjacency matrix of a
new graph called the transitive
closure of my input graph.
So, breadth first search,
yeah, good.
So, all I need to do is find
shortest paths,
and if the weights come out
infinity, then there's no path.
If it's less than infinity,
that there's a path.
And so here,
so you are saying maybe I don't
care about the weights,
so I can run breadth first
search n times,
and that will work indeed.
So, if we do B times B of S,
so it's maybe weird that I'm
covering here in the middle,
but it's just an interlude.
So, we have,
then, something like V times E.
OK, you can run any of these
algorithms.
You could take Floyd-Warshall
for example.
Why not?
OK, then it would just be V^ I
mean, you could run in any of
these algorithms with weights of
one or zero, and just check
whether the values are infinity
or not.
So, I mean, t_ij equals zero,
if and only if the shortest
path weight from i to j is
infinity.
So, just solve this.
This is an easier problem than
shortest paths.
It is, in fact,
strictly easier in a certain
sense, because what's going on
with transitive closure,
and I just want to mention this
out of interest because
transitive closure is a useful
thing to know about.
Essentially,
what we are doing,
let me get this right,
is using a different set of
operators.
We're using or and and,
a logical or and and instead of
min and plus,
OK, because we want to know,
if you think about a
relaxation, in some sense,
maybe I should think about it
in terms of this min.
So, if I want to know,
is there a pathway from I to j
that uses vertices labeled one
through k in the middle?
Well, either there is a path
that doesn't use the vertex k,
or there is a path that uses k,
and then it would have to look
like that.
OK, so there would have to be a
path here, and there would have
to be a path there.
So, the min and plus get
replaced with or and and.
And if you remember,
this used to be plus,
and this used to be product in
the matrix world.
So, plus is now like or.
And, multiply is now like and,
which sounds very good,
right?
Plus does feel like or,
and multiply does feel like and
if you live in a zero-one world.
So, in fact,
this is not quite the field Z
mod two, but this is a good,
nice, field to work in.
This is the Boolean world.
So, I'll just write Boole.
Good old Boole knows all about
this.
It's like his master's thesis,
I think, talking about Boolean
algebra.
And, this actually means that
you can use fast matrix
multiply.
You can use Strassen's
algorithm, and the fancier
algorithms, and you can compute
the transitive closure in
subcubic time.
So, this is sub cubic if the
edges are sparse.
But, it's cubic in the worst
case if there are lots of edges.
This is cubic.
You can actually do better
using Strassen.
So, I'll just say you can do
it.
No details here.
I think it should be,
so in fact, there is a theorem.
This is probably not in the
textbook, but there's a theorem
that says transitive closure is
just as hard as matrix multiply.
OK, they are equivalent.
Their running times are the
same.
We don't know how long it takes
to do a matrix multiply over a
field.
It's somewhere between n^2 and
n^2.3.
But, whatever the answer is:
same for transitive closure.
OK, there's the interlude.
And that's where we actually
get to use Strassen and friends.
Remember, Strassen was n to the
log base two of seven algorithm.
Remember that,
especially on the final.
Those are things you should
have at the tip of your tongue.
OK, the last algorithm we're
going to cover is really going
to build on what we saw last
time: Johnson's algorithm.
And, I've lost some of the
running times here.
But, when we had unweighted
graphs, we could do all pairs
really fast, just as fast as a
single source Bellman-Ford.
That's kind of nifty.
We don't know how to improve
Bellman-Ford in the single
source case.
So, we can't really help to get
anything better than V times E.
And, if you remember running V
times Dijkstra,
V times Dijkstra was about the
same.
So, just put this in the recall
bubble here: V times Dijkstra
would give us V times E plus V^2
log V.
And, if you ignore that log
factor, this is just VE.
OK, so this was really good.
Dijkstra was great.
And this was for nonnegative
edge weights.
So, with negative edge weights,
somehow we'd like to get the
same running time.
Now, how might I get the same
running time?
Well, it would be really nice
if I could use Dijkstra.
Of course, Dijkstra doesn't
work with negative weights.
So what could I do?
What would I hope to do?
What could I hope to?
Suppose I want,
in the middle of the algorithm,
it says run Dijkstra n times.
Then, what should I do to
prepare for that?
Make all the weights positive,
or nonnegative.
Why not, right?
We're being wishful thinking.
That's what we'll do.
So, this is called graph
re-weighting.
And, what's cool is we actually
already know how to do it.
We just don't know that we know
how to do it.
But I know that we know that we
know how to do it.
You don't yet know that we know
that I know that we know how to
do it.
So, it turns out you can
re-weight the vertices.
So, at the end of the last
class someone asked me,
can you just,
like, add the same weight to
all the edges?
That doesn't work.
Not quite, because different
paths have different numbers of
edges.
What we are going to do is add
a particular weight to each
vertex.
What does that mean?
Well, because we really only
have weights on the edges,
here's what well do.
We'll re-weight each edge,
so, (u,v), let's say,
going to go back into graph
speak instead of matrix speak,
(u,v) instead of I and j,
and we'll call this modified
weight w_h.
h is our function.
It gives us a number for every
vertex.
And, it's just going to be the
old weight of that edge plus the
weight of the start vertex minus
the weight of the terminating
vertex.
I'm sure these have good names.
One of these is the head,
and the other is the tail,
but I can never remember which.
OK, so we've directed edge
(u,v).
Just add one of them;
subtract the other.
And, it's a directed edge,
so that's a consistent
definition.
OK, so that's called
re-weighting.
Now, this is actually a
theorem.
If you do this,
then, let's say,
for any vertices,
u and v in the graph,
for any two vertices,
all paths from u to v have the
same weight as they did before,
well, not quite.
They have the same
re-weighting.
So, if you look at all the
different paths and you say,
well, what's the difference
between vh, well,
sorry, let's say delta,
which is the old shortest
paths, and deltas of h,
which is the shortest path
weights according to this new
weight function,
then that difference is the
same.
So, we'll say that all these
paths are re-weighted by the
same amounts.
OK, this is actually a
statement about all paths,
not just shortest paths.
There we go.
OK, to how many people is this
obvious already?
A few, yeah,
it is.
And what's the one word?
OK, it's maybe not that
obvious.
All right, shout out the word
when you figure it out.
Meanwhile, I'll write out this
rather verbose proof.
There's a one word proof,
still waiting.
So, let's just take one of
these paths that starts at u and
ends at v.
Take any path.
We're just going to see what
its new weight is relative to
its old weight.
And so, let's just write out
w_h of the path,
which we define in the usual
way as the sum over all edges of
the new weight of the edge from
v_i to v_i plus one.
Do you have the word?
No?
Tough puzzle then,
OK.
So that's the definition of the
weight of a path.
And, then we know this thing is
just w of v_i,
v_i plus one.
I'll get it right,
plus the weight of the first
vertex, plus,
sorry, the re-weighting of v_i
minus the re-weighting of v_i
plus one.
This is all in parentheses
that's summed over I.
Now I need the magic word.
Telescopes, good.
Now this is obvious:
each of these telescopes with
an extra previous,
except the very beginning and
the very end.
So, this is the sum of these
weights of edges,
but then outside the sum,
we have plus h of v_1,
and minus h of v_k.
OK, those guys don't quite
cancel.
We're not looking at a cycle,
just a path.
And, this thing is just w of
the path, as this is the normal
weight of the path.
And so the change,
the difference between w_h of P
and w of P is this thing,
which is just h of u minus h of
v.
And, the point is that's the
same as long as you fix the
endpoints, u and v,
of the shortest path,
you're changing this path
weight by the same thing for all
paths.
This is for any path from u to
v, and that proves the theorem.
So, the one word here was
telescopes.
These change in weights
telescope over any path.
Therefore, if we want to find
shortest paths,
you just find the shortest
paths in this re-weighted
version, and then you just
change it by this one amount.
You subtract off this amount
instead of adding it.
That will give you the shortest
path weight in the original
weights.
OK, so this is a tool.
We now know how to change
weights in the graph.
But what we really want is to
change weights in the graph so
that the weights all come out
nonnegative.
OK, how do we do that?
Why in the world would there be
a function, h,
that makes all the edge weights
nonnegative?
It doesn't make sense.
It turns out we already know.
So, I should write down this
consequence.
Let me get this in the right
order.
So in particular,
the shortest path changes by
this amount.
And if you want to know this
value, you just move the stuff
to the other side.
So, we compute deltas of h,
then we can compute delta.
That's the consequence here.
How many people here pronounce
this word corollary?
OK, and how many people
pronounce it corollary?
Yeah, we are alone.
Usually get at least one other
student, and they're usually
Canadian or British or
something.
I think that the accent.
So, I always avoid pronouncing
his word unless I really think,
it's corollary,
and get it right.
I at least say Z not Zed.
OK, here we go.
So, what we want to do is find
one of these functions.
I mean, let's just write down
what we could hope to have.
We want to find a re-weighted
function, h, the signs of weight
to each vertex such that w_h of
(u,v) is nonnegative.
That would be great for all
edges, all (u,v) in E.
OK, then we could run Dijkstra.
We could run Dijkstra,
get the delta h's,
and then just undo the
re-weighting,
and get what we want.
And, that is Johnson's
algorithm.
The claim is that this is
always possible.
OK, why should it always be
possible?
Well, let's look at this
constraint.
w_h of (u,v) is that.
So, it's w of (u,v) plus h of u
minus h of V should be
nonnegative.
Let me rewrite this a little
bit.
I'm going to put these guys
over here.
That would be the right thing,
h of v minus h of u is less
than or equal to w of (u,v).
Does that look familiar?
Did I get it right?
It should be right.
Anyone seen that inequality
before?
Yeah, yes, correct answer.
OK, where?
In a previous lecture?
In the previous lecture.
What is this called if I
replace h with x?
Charles knows.
Good, anyone else remember all
the way back to episode two?
I know there was a weekend.
What's this operator called?
Not subtraction but,
I think I heard it,
oh man.
All right, I'll tell you.
It's a difference constraint,
all right?
This is the difference
operator.
OK, it's our good friend
difference constraints.
So, this is what we want to
satisfy.
We have a system of difference
constraints.
h of V minus h of u should be,
we want to find these.
These are our unknowns.
Subject to these constraints,
we are given the w's.
Now, we know in these
difference constraints are
satisfiable.
Can someone tell me when these
constraints are satisfiable?
We know exactly when for any
set of difference constraints.
You've got to remember the
math.
Terminology,
I can understand.
It's hard to remember words
unless you're a linguist,
perhaps.
So, when is the system of
different constraints
satisfiable?
All right, you should
definitely, very good.
[LAUGHTER] Yes,
very good.
Someone brought their lecture
notes: when the constraint graph
has no negative weight cycles.
Good, thank you.
Now, what is the constraint
graph?
OK, this has a one letter
answer more or less.
I'll accept the one letter
answer.
What?
A?
A: close.
G.
Yeah, I mean,
same thing.
Yeah, so the constraint graph
is essentially G.
Actually, it is G.
The constraint graph is G,
good.
And, we prove this by adding a
new source for text,
and connecting that to
everyone.
But that's sort of beside the
point.
That was in order to actually
satisfy them.
But this is our
characterization.
So, if we assume that there are
no negative weight cycles in our
graph, which we've been doing
all the time,
then we know that this thing is
satisfiable.
Therefore, there is an
assignment of this h's.
There is a re-weighting that
makes all the weights
nonnegative.
Then we can run Dijkstra.
OK, we're done.
Isn't that cool?
And how do we satisfy these
constraints?
We know how to do that with one
run of Bellman-Ford,
which costs order VE,
which is less than V times
Dijkstra.
So, that's it,
write down the details
somewhere.
So, this is Johnson's
algorithm.
This is the fanciest of them
all.
It will be our fastest,
all pairs shortest path
algorithm.
So, the claim is,
we can find a function,
h, from V to R such that the
modified weight of every edge is
nonnegative for every edge,
(u,v), in our graph.
And, we do that using
Bellman-Ford to solve the
difference constraints.
These are exactly the different
constraints that we were born to
solve that we learned to solve
last time.
The graphs here are
corresponding exactly if you
look back at the definition.
Or, Bellman-Ford will tell us
that there is a negative weight
cycle.
OK, great, so it's not that we
really have to assume that there
is no negative weight cycle.
We'll get to know.
And if your fancy,
you can actually figure out the
minus infinities from this.
But, at this point,
I just want to think about the
case where there is no negative
weight cycle.
But if there is,
we can find out that it exists,
and that just tell the user.
OK, then we'd stop.
Otherwise, there is no negative
weight cycle.
Therefore, there is an
assignment that gives is
nonnegative edge weights.
So, we just use it.
We use it to run Dijkstra.
So, step two is,
oh, I should say the running
time of all this is V times E.
So, we're just running
Bellman-Ford on exactly the
input graph.
Plus, we add a source,
if you recall,
to solve a set of difference
constraints.
You add a source vertex,
S, connected to everyone at
weight zero, run Bellman-Ford
from there because we don't have
a source here.
We just have a graph.
We want to know all pairs.
So, this, you can use to find
whether there is a negative
weight cycle anywhere.
Or, we get this magic
assignment.
So now, w_h is nonnegative,
so we can run Dijkstra on w_h.
We'll say, using w_h,
so you compute w_h.
That takes linear time.
And, we run Dijkstra for each
possible source.
I'll write this out explicitly.
We've had this in our minds
several times.
But, when we said n times
Dijkstra over n times BFS,
here it is.
We want to compute delta sub h
now, of (u,v) for all V,
and we do this separately for
all u.
And so, the running time here
is VE plus V^2 log V.
This is just V times the
running time of Dijkstra,
which is E plus V log V.
OK, it happens that this term
is the same as this one,
which is nice,
because that means step one
costs us nothing asymptotically.
OK, and then,
last step is,
well, now we know delta h.
We just need to compute delta.
So, for each pair of vertices,
we'll call it (u,v),
we just compute what the
original weights would be,
so what delta (u,v) is.
And we can do that using this
corollary.
It's just delta sub h of (u,v)
minus h of u plus h of v.
I got the signs right.
Yeah, so this takes V^2 time,
also dwarfed by the running
time of Dijkstra.
So, the overall running time of
Johnson's algorithm is just the
running time of step two,
running Dijkstra n times --
-- which is pretty cool.
When it comes to single source
shortest paths,
Bellman-Ford is the best thing
for general weights.
Dijkstra is the best thing for
nonnegative weights.
But for all pair shortest
paths, we can skirt the whole
negative weight issue by using
this magic we saw from
Bellman-Ford.
But now, running Dijkstra n
times, which is still the best
thing we know how to do,
pretty much,
for the all pairs nonnegative
weights, now we can do it for
general weights too,
which is a pretty nice
combination of all the
techniques we've seen.
In the trilogy,
and along the way,
we saw lots of dynamic
programming, which is always
good practice.
Any questions?
This is the last new content
lecture before the quiz.
On Wednesday it will be quiz
review, if I recall correctly.
And then it's Thanksgiving,
so there's no recitation.
And then the quiz starts on
Monday.
So, study up.
See you then.